new this morning the rescue robot a pet
pal the Firefly breathing apparatus so
these are just a few of the inventions
on display today at Artemis ham Concert
Hall at UNLV for the senior design
competition yeah more than 30
engineering students they're amazing
they're competing in front of a panel of
Industry experts our Candace Charles is
there at UNLV with one of those teams
show us these brilliant young men and
women Candace
good morning YouTube good morning folks
I am joined by some of the real world
problem solvers of tomorrow I don't know
they like that title as much but you
know what I'm gonna give it to them
anyway and this is one of the great
teams as we mentioned I have Evander
here with me and nabel thank you so much
for joining me this morning tell us a
little about your project so our project
is actually an acute injury Contour
splint we actually have two parts to the
splint so a couple semesters ago a
different senior Design Group focused on
like the cryotherapy portion that our
splint is actually accompanying but our
splint is actually made for acute
injuries so it's for injuries that
happen
and we wanted to be put on like within
the first six hours of that injury
happening okay okay so this makes it
easier and quicker for people to get the
job done and get back to what they got
to do right yep yeah so the main focus
of this is to obviously Advance the
healing process and get some sort of
remedy on that broken ankle you know
within minutes of after the injury
happens nice and you have a whole team
here you guys all worked on this
together tell us about that process I
know it takes some time right
it really does uh we've been working
since I mean last last spring really
about eight months in over the summer
time even we weren't in classroom there
was no instruction we were constantly
working on these splints just the
prototyping designing and all that I
mean we're a long way from January and
we you know hopefully all our hard work
shows off awesome well good luck to you
guys and congratulations already for all
the hard work you guys have been doing
now this is just one of more than 30
teams winning 150 students involved in
this competition they have some amazing
judges and you guys can come by and
check out their projects starting at one
o'clock they're already here though
starting to get ready for you and
waiting for you but I'm gonna toss it
back to you guys in the studio as I talk
to them about these projects because I
kind of want to know it you know how do
you get these things going what do I
need to do to become one of these great
minds they're brainy for sure Candice
[Laughter]